Michael why do you say that Talent
cannot be taught I think Talent is
something that that people just have or
they don't like if I had a script
a six-page audition for a television
show or a movie and I gave it to 100
people randomly on the street a certain
number of them would be able to look at
it read it and kind of make it
responsive and somewhat real
and many of them wouldn't that's I mean
the base level of talent from my
definition is having great first
instincts because you have to
particularly in film and television
there's no there's not a lot of
rehearsal there's not a lot of time to
sort of find your character and all that
stuff so your instincts are your first
instinct
if it's right about 75 80 percent of the
time that to me is the Baseline level of
the definition of talent I don't think
you can teach it you can teach strategy
you can teach people to be better with
what talent level they have
but I don't I think Talent is just
something people have or they don't and
and you see it in children I mean you
see it in little kids so I I
I don't know if that answers the
question but that's how I feel about it
instinct sure and and maybe give
it full sure
so
um when you're an actor is the is the
slave is too strong or where the actor
is obedient to the text
the text is everything at least that's
how I was taught that's how I was
trained and so the instinct is when you
look at something very quickly like if I
get an audition for for a TV show or a
movie
and there's very little time I look at
it quickly and I go because also I'm
seasoned and I've done this a long time
it's not like I'm a 23 year old anymore
so I could look at it and instantly have
a take on how it's supposed to go for me
it's rhythmical and it's outside in
meaning uh I work on externals and I
wasn't taught that fact that that was
oppositional to how I was taught
inside meaning uh
thinking about it wondering about it
dredging up some old experience in your
life to somehow illuminate it I worked
with externals and so it it helps me
when you talk about the Instinct and
having the idea to just look at
something quickly we call that in the
business they call that a cold read like
here's a cold can you cold read this in
other words you just look at it and you
read it and you have something or you
don't
that's talent and that's Instinct and I
kind of don't think that can be taught I
think you either have that or you don't
training helps that I mean when you have
good foundational training
it helps that because you are in
practice and you're getting better at uh
being able to you you get better faster
we have particularly in film and
television you have to get better faster
you have to find a way to short circuit
and get to the results faster
so let's say you know how they mention
of people certain people have more
Street smarts than others or those in
combat certain people just kind of
thrive in those situations there's
something innate in them is that similar
to being on stage and working with
another person in front of you
yeah I think that's actually a really
good analogy it's interesting I I had a
woman in the very first class that I
taught who was a friend of mine from the
voiceover business and she was not an
actor
she was mostly a writer and a really
interesting creative person
highly creative highly imaginative funny
but not a trained actor but she wanted
to take this acting class
and she would come in every week with
results from the work she was doing
outside of class
that were weird and interesting and fun
and not typical actor stuff it was
off-center a little bit and I finally
said to her I just want to know because
you don't have
you really don't have a foundational
training that a lot of people have how
do you arrive at that what is your what
is your process
and she said well I just pretend that
what's happening is happening to me
I went okay we can all go home now
that's the lesson because that for film
acting in particular I come from the
theater originally but for film acting
it is a personal identity art form you
are the vessel through which the story
flows
I don't know if I answered your question
you did yeah did she continue on or she
just wanted to be there she just did
well she did for a while I think she was
in class for maybe a year and she had
fun and it was great for her and it I
think it helped
um it helps her other work which was
voice over and writing
because it's all kind of the same I mean
it's different it's in different silos
but it's really all the same it's all
the same Instinct it's all the same
creative impulse to do something look
when you have like I have two sons who
are grown up now and married and all
that but when they were little kids
they no one had to teach them to run
around the house with a hat on and
pretend they were a Power Ranger or
whatever it was they were pretending to
be that's just a human hardwired
instinct to play and transform
and I don't think that's taught I think
it is Vogler and I when I did the
interview with Chris Vogler talked about
story also being just sort of hardwired
into the species the hero and all of
that and little kids you see them doing
that I think with actors in particular
it's getting back to that original
impulse to play and transform that makes
it um
it but a lot of stuff gets in the way I
mean life gets in the way and and how
you're raised gets in the way and the
things you've been taught to behave
yourself and get in line and all that
stuff gets in the way and the people
were never got in the way are the people
who have an open Open Door
you know I say that with people I can
help you if the door is open if the door
is closed I mean nobody can help you
so is that why with uh comedic timing as
well certain stand-ups let's say Robin
Williams
it was it was like some other being was
inside of him yeah I mean I think it is
I think it is I think it is
that's a really good question and I
don't really have a nuanced answer for
it but I do think I can remember when I
was a little kid
making people laugh and not knowing why
they were laughing but I knew how to do
it
but I wasn't sure why they were laughing
but I knew how to be funny
where does that come from I have no idea
but it was uh I I told the story
yesterday to a student of mine who came
by for a for a session and
I was talking about
um one of the things
I will not have a second book but if I
ever did have a second book it would be
called worlds and faces because I think
that's what TV and film is It's All
About Faces and worlds because everybody
at the professional level is pretty
talented so it's not about that it's
about where do you fit where does this
fit into that world
SWAT is a world NCIS is a world Downton
Abbey is a world they're all different
where do you fit it's all about fit so I
told her this story is comes back to
your question about comedic timing
I had an audition for Seinfeld that I'd
never been up for that show that I
always wanted to be on that show because
it's such a cool show it's still a cool
show it's still very funny
and I had this line uh first of all I
walked in the room and and Jerry
Seinfeld was in the room which
kind of freaked me out
um it was exciting you know because I
love him I still love him I think he's
brilliant and my first I'm trying I'm
working for the New York Mets and I'm
trying to get George to get himself
fired so he can come work for the Mets
and my first line is and it's not to me
it's not a funny line but the first line
is George the Mets need a new head of
scouting and we think that someone might
be you that's the line it's not really a
funny line I said that line
and Seinfeld almost fell off the chair
laughing and I thought
what just happened here
that's interesting
somehow I fit in that world he thought
that was funny for whatever reason I
don't know I can't quantify it but it's
I think it's just genetic when you talk
about Robin Williams or any of these
other brilliant
um comedic Minds I do think it is kind
of just you know when you're a little
kid you become the class clown you
become the one who entertains everybody
and if you're continue to be crazy
enough you become you become a stand-up
comedian
I and that scene is on your reel correct
I think it is yeah it's very funny
you're with you're in a diet at the
diner yeah
yeah we'll have a link to your real uh
down below people can look at it
why do you say that desire cannot be
taught desire for success is different
than desire I think
desire to be great to be an artist to be
outstanding at what you do is very
different than the desire for success
and I think it's look there are people
who are just inordinately ambitious
right out of the shoot they just are
um
but I don't think I can be taught I
think what you I've I've always said
this and I think it's true
foreign
I can't teach Talent we talked about I
can't teach desire but what I really
teach well I think is
a strategy for the senior working on
right now for the project that that's a
part of for your career and for your
life if I don't get too life coachy
about this but it's kind of all the same
it's understanding
that your innate talent and desire is
just there or it's not I mean I have run
across people
who are very talented and don't have the
fire in the belly to be successful they
don't care about it they're not it's
they're perfectly willing to be
just in the mix
I I taught a I taught the first time I
ever taught anything this was at the
Hawaii International Film Festival a
long time ago and it was uh
fantastic gig because you got to spent
two weeks in Hawaii
and I taught a week-long workshop
for actors and there were a number of
actors there who live there and and all
that
and there was an older gentleman
um who was auditing he wasn't part of
the actual workshop and he was we had
people who were auditing and all that
just to sort of
hang out and be and see it and observe
it and all that at the end of the week
he came up to me with some questions
and he said
um you know I was an actor
I said oh yeah and I said you were very
familiar looking so I probably have seen
you and and yeah he said I was I was an
actor in in did some TV and a little bit
of movies and
he was older and I guess had retired and
he said you know I said I just thought
if I can just make a living at this
he said and that's all I ever did was
just just make a living at it
and I took that to mean and he and he
this is what he meant that he never sets
his sights high enough he was just
satisfied being in the mix just
satisfied being on set just satisfied
getting that call that he got a call
back he wasn't he didn't aim high enough
and if you aim up here
you might get here but if you aim here
you're gonna get there you're going to
get so that desire I don't know I don't
know where it comes from I mean a lot of
it's cultural depends on what culture
you're from and and you know whether
it's
um a minority culture or you know like
in my case I'm Jewish and it was just
always imbued in us that you've got to
be you've got to be better than
everybody because you're going to be
judged harsher in a more harsh way and
all that so I don't know that was
you learn at your on your daddy's knee I
guess
what if we take the flip side and that
is someone who is maybe not that
talented but is incredibly ambitious
whether it's cultural or they want to
show those folks back in high school or
whatever it is
how do you reconcile that someone who
keeps trying and banging their head
against a wall but it's just not there
well
um
how do they reconcile that I don't know
I I do think that um
Talent is a commodity tell everybody at
the professional level is talented
enough to be in
you know the rookie or or 911 or some of
these kind of b-minus network shows they
don't mean to insult anybody but you
know they're not the same as the
streaming shows there's much higher
quality so they're talented enough and
there are people who are what I call
like mono talents they have like they do
one thing
but they do it really well and it's it's
commoditized
and they become a go-to person for that
one thing
and you've seen people we've all seen
people go oh it's that same guy he's
doing the same you know he's he's the
security guard who's always talking into
this and whatever A lot of it is just is
I don't really know I mean there are
people
um who are who are
there's an actor I won't mention him
because I won't mention it but uh wildly
ambitious I mean I have never in my life
been around anybody
where every breath of every day was in
the furtherance of their Ambitions it
was breathtaking
and this person succeeded greatly
talented
absolutely talented but
um
I think that you know it leads to kind
of uh
not kind of it leads to kind of an
unbalanced life when you are that way
and I don't think people who are that
way can't really control that that's
just how they're wired I think a lot of
this comes down to
how you're wired I mean I interview
people frequently uh to be in our studio
and I don't take everybody because I
don't want to and I don't need to so I I
really I don't know any other way to do
it I just say hey let's let's meet or
not now it's kind of on Zoom like we
meet on Zoom
and tell me what you're after and let's
see if we're rowing the boat in the same
direction and if we're not you won't
hurt my feelings
so the people I have pardon me
in my circle of of students and
colleagues and clients are all people
I've curated let's say
and so I I get
consistently I'll say people will say
it's an incredible group of people just
a remarkable group I said yeah it is
because I take the time to get to know
them a little bit and not everybody gets
who wants in gets in exactly so
um I forget the original question what
was your original question about desire
being taught but I love what you're
saying here and that not everybody that
comes in to audit the class or be part
of your class is the fit
how can you tell somebody really wants
it
um
I don't know how I can describe that but
you the first thing I will do is
um I have I have two exercises I do with
new new students and sometimes I do it
when I'm meeting people to to be
involved in the studio
one is something that's standard and one
is something I made up and the one
that's standard is I'll say show me
something whether you want to do it live
or on Zoom or you've taped it show me
something you're really good at I want
to say something that you're really good
at that you think this shows everything
that I really want to show
and most actors have something like that
in their back pocket a piece they did in
a play or a speech in a movie or
something they did in the class that
they think this kills
so that's what you can do
that's what you can I want to see what
you can do
now on the other hand I want to see who
you are so I said I want you to write
something
and a lot of actors kind of roll their
eyes they don't like to write but um
I said I want to know what you know
I want to know what you know what do you
know
I want to know what you know about how
you get up in the morning and how you
like your coffee and and traffic and
your dog and and start every sentence
but this is what I know I know that I
said and don't edit it just write it
stream of Consciousness I don't need to
know anything you don't want anyone else
to know I don't need to know anybody's
deepest darkest Secrets this is not
therapy this is your world view I want
to see your world view and I want to see
what you can do what you can do and who
you are who you are always trumps the
world view in film and television
personal identity art form that's it's
it's maybe always been that way
but it's more that way now it's how else
do you explain certain actors I've used
I use it in my in my TED Talk I use Seth
Rogen as an example right I mean
I think he's great but he does that
he does he's the best Seth Rogen he
could possibly be and no one else does
that and his because he has a world view
because you know immediately when he
comes into
some sort of transaction in the scene
you know immediately I was going to
respond because his worldview is so
clear
most actors don't have that because
we're trained to be somebody else
we're trained to be
um
your effect you're applauded to be you
know oh I didn't even see you there I
didn't recognize you
that's not what film and TV is about and
that was kind of the the Genesis of my
deciding eventually that I was going to
try to teach was to sort of
try to teach to that perspective because
I didn't see anybody else doing that
and so when someone comes in and they do
the writing exercise of of this is what
I know
um I know I like my coffee with cinnamon
I know that I um like to wake up and
check Twitter you know if if they seem
reluctant
to do that exercise do you see that
maybe there's not a willingness yeah
sometimes or
when we were we're still we're back in
person now we were on Zoom for a couple
years as I'm sure you know and uh when
we were in person before it was like
first of all you're coming in you don't
know anybody in this class
you're speaking about how you see the
world around you in front of a room full
of strangers out loud
that's risky
it's a little risky that's why I say
don't I don't want to know anything you
don't want anyone else to know I don't
need to know no one needs to know that I
just need to know how you see the things
how you how you interact with the world
around you and so yes people will get
they're either like they pull back from
it or they're trying to be clever and
it's not really clever or they're uh
they find themselves getting caught up
in it and getting emotional
because and I'll often say no did you
learn anything about yourself that you
didn't know before you did that and some
of them say yeah that was really
interesting because we know these things
but to actually write them out
and speak them
is different
and that's I mean that's the only time I
do that and it's It's Tricky it is
tricky and this there's a whole
um
in all of the training of artists
whether it's acting music
there is a teacher student relationship
that's tricky you know the the whole
Guru thing which is very prominent which
I really abhor uh so you have to be
super careful even more so today with
our world today you just have to be
super careful that you're not
um
leading them into territory they don't
want to go into and I make that's I make
that very clear and and knock on wood
I've never really had anything that was
like a train wreck with that exercise
and what about when
one thinks they know themselves but then
they are in a room of strangers with
something quite innocent revealing about
themselves nothing no deep dark secret
and the room shows them they're not who
they thought they were
does that happen that's not
um I don't think it's ever happened like
that I used to also do an exercise
though that might
play into that
um idea
I would say
I've done this one for a long time
somebody would walk up on stage say
their name and uh I don't know I've
given the sentence like you know hi my
name is Michael Laskin I'm whatever give
them something to say and everybody
would have to instantly write down three
words
like what did you get from that
from that blink of an eye thing it's
that blink of an eye thing that is so
we have that in in in life I mean
somebody comes to my door to deliver
something or or a friend or a relative
we have an immediate human reaction to
that person it's the same thing on
screen it's exactly the same thing on
screen so when I started acting I didn't
under when I started acting on film and
television I didn't understand that at
all and I was not good
I I was not good initially I really
wasn't I mean I had to learn that it's a
different thing entirely
and that began my education toward what
I'm trying to teach now
to show yourself you have to know
yourself what does this mean
let me let me Circle back on something
to answer that
um I was trained in the theater
and it was the serious theater and I'm
not making fun of that but it was I mean
we thought we were going to change the
world
doing theater
um it was a real passion for me
and still is I I love it and I I do it I
still do it occasionally but you don't
have to show yourself in the theater you
show the character you show
your version of that character
but in film and television you have you
you can't escape showing yourself
and the minute you try to escape it you
look terrible as I said my my first few
TV things that I watched were just I
thought at least to my standards I
thought were really bad I thought oh I
have a lot to learn and so to know your
you know
you can't when I teach because I do like
you can't teach someone about their
identity uh I'm not talking about
identity sexual identity I'm talking
about personal identity
um you can't teach that but you can
curate it a little bit and I do think
I always say you know lead
late examine life do something that's
outside of this
acting stuff
plant a garden refinish a piece of
furniture do something tangible do
something and read and and create
uh
Heroes for yourself I always say
artistic Heroes they don't have to be
actors or they can be musicians they can
be art visual artists
so to know yourself I think when you get
older and I am older uh I'm really old
uh you I think it's a natural process
you get to know yourself better if if
you're open to that some people just
aren't some people never know themselves
I'm not talking about those people but
you know the more enlightened
self-examined person and you naturally
get to the truth about you
later in life you just and as an actor
uh that it it kind of becomes easier
because you don't have to
Push It Forward you don't have to push
it out it's just there it just lives
with you but when you're younger
you don't have any of that you're trying
to impress you're trying to be something
bigger greater grander uh you're trying
to you're just constantly trying to
figure out who you are
I mean some people look some people
never know who they are some people know
who they are the minute they're born I
mean that there's a wide spectrum of
that but I do think to particularly if
we're talking about and we are talking
about acting and film acting in
particular
I think you do have to know
who you are and and it's it's um
again hard to hard to
point to a finger to it but there are
certain people who have qualities
like we were just you know uh the other
moment talking about Tom Cruise and Will
Smith and people like that
Tom Cruise who I happen to think is a
really good actor right kind of an
unpopular opinion in some circles but I
think he's very talented so do I yeah um
it's
who is he I don't really know who he is
but I do know that he is dead certain
about everything
he is certain he Harbors No Doubt
and that's a really attractive trait we
all want to be like that that's a
classic hero trade so whether he's
really like that I'm not sure but he's
awfully good at convincing me that he is
there's there's a there's a a certitude
about what he does
and to me that's kind of what makes a
star and there aren't too many stars
left in in the film world
so that core essential quality of in his
case dead servitude
you know has no doesn't question
nothing doesn't question things but he
doesn't question what he has to do
that's so attractive to watch as you
know if you're if you're into Hero
Stories and and heroic stuff I don't
know if you saw the latest Top Gun
uh not yet it's great I mean it is what
it is it's it's it's a Thrill Ride but
it's great he's great in it and
um he combines that with a very high
level of skill
and so yeah he's I mean I I don't I
don't never worked with him don't know
him I know people who have worked with
him will speak very highly of him in a
work environment
so I mean he's but there's so few people
like that I think because the system we
have
now it's it's all about imperfect he's
about perfection
he presents a perfect version of
um of himself in a way
we are much more interested in
imperfection I think as viewers we want
to see kind of the dirty messy stuff we
want to see the doubts we want to see
people having crises
and so the classic hero who has no
doubt and who knows what he or she has
to do is so rare today but I think it's
also like super attractive and I think
it's perennial I just think it's great
and even other rules that he was in that
weren't sort of the top gun Maverick
roles uh you know All the Right Moves
Risky Business
um still he had something in him where
you were just so drawn uh the firm and
at times he was being gaslit during the
and then he figured out okay wait a
minute exactly and and you went along on
that ride with him and yes he does have
this sort of unshakable where you're
like man I wish I could yeah he's going
to get it done right Tom's going to get
it done and he has Integrity too he has
Integrity in these roles like his his
characters always well let's not forget
Les Grossman and traffic Thunder have
you seen traffic Thunder I haven't
that was a that was a complete
um anomaly he plays this insane Studio
executive named Les Grossman
it's crazy and you go like oh you can do
that that's interesting right I've heard
of parts of the movie yeah I would now
I'll have to go not a movie you could
make today yeah politically correct
climate you could not make that movie
but I've seen the trailer yeah yeah
right what's the difference between an
actor and an authentic actor
um
an authentic actor is using him or
herself as the prism through which we
see the character
not unlike the story I told earlier
about the woman who said I just pretend
that what's happening is happening to me
I I interpret authenticness authenticity
authenticness is that a word I don't
even know it is now okay great I
interpret that as being something that
is
self-based in other words we want to
know how you
react to this situation it's personal it
is it is personal to you you're not
representing your you're not
transforming your informing if that
makes sense transformative acting the
kind that Meryl Streep sometimes gets to
do in Daniel Day Lewis and Anthony
Hopkins these are all incredible actors
most actors don't get a chance to do
that work because they just don't there
isn't that much of it and it goes to
those kind of folks
so we basically have to play
a truthful Dynamic version of Who We Are
to some extent to a large extent most of
the time and that is
the more you can lean into Who You Are
now it has to be mated
pardon me it has to be mated to a skill
set that that works and that is
[Music]
um
professional and and correct and that's
where I see
I do see a lot today
a diminution in that
and sort of basic skill set I have
actors where I will say
I'm not actually understanding what
you're saying
like it's not clear it's not vocally
it's not clear do you know what that
word means no well there's a dictionary
there's a thing called Google look it up
I want to you know I want you to be
there's a there's there's no lack of
reality and authenticity there is a lack
of imagination and curiosity not it's
not rampant but I see that I see people
who are incurious and don't want they
just think oh if I just behave naturally
it'll be cool it'll be like that'll be
no no that's not it that's just the base
level of realistic behavior is not
acting realistic behavior is just
Behavior
acting has a strategy you have to figure
out the actor has to figure out
where the scene's going
if if the scene is an aria what's the
high note and why where does it change
what's the pre you know this is how I
work with auditions which I do a lot of
I do a lot of private audition coaching
and I've done thousands of these now so
I've figured it out and I've learned
myself
you know you have to sometimes teach
yourself like oh I'm not doing that I
have to figure out how to do that but
like with an audition you get whatever
you get you get six or eight pages two
or three scenes whatever and no time to
really work on it
um
these are standard things but they may
not be standard to to you or your
listeners I say what's the moment before
what just happened before this scene
how does that inform how it starts so it
has to have a dynamic beginning it has
to be in the flow of what just happened
you may not have the screenplay you may
not even know that so you have to kind
of make it up and figure out what's the
tone of the speech what's the genre of
this piece what makes sense what could
be the moment before this happens then
where does the scene change and why and
how do you mark that so those are all
like strategy things that you have to be
well trained to understand and most
people are but you do get I do get some
people that are just
they it's not get that or you know I I
did a
perfect example of this is I did a guest
star a couple years ago on big little
lies which was a fantastic show
and because it was a David Kelly show uh
who's one of the elite writer creators
in television I mean Ally McBeal and all
kinds of the shows
I know having worked I worked on a lot
of Stephen bochko shows back in the day
and you don't change a syllable you
don't change you could have the greatest
take in the world if one word is off
they don't print it gotta do it again
so the same thing I thought was David
Kelly and who I had worked for but a
long time previous
so I was encouraged that the director
this wonderful British woman named
Andrea Arnold who directed the season
that I was in
she really wanted the the first A.D this
this woman who was the first assistant
director said now just on my first day
on the session I just want you to know
that Andrea doesn't say action
and she doesn't say cut
I said oh well what does she say well
she's probably going to want you to talk
your way into the scene into the flow of
the beginning of the scene and when she
feels you're in the right place where
the scene begins she'll probably say
something like okay off you go
which is exactly what she did
it was so liberating because usually
it's like action and everyone like
tenses up and he
it was a fantastic way to work
and so I've I stole that from her in a
way I mean it's not an original idea but
to really talk your way particularly if
like now the actors are taping stuff on
the in their homes for auditions and so
I said let's improv into the scene just
cut out the stuff that's not on the page
when you actually edit it but then
you're in the flow of what just happened
and that's really screen acting is so
different because you're playing little
pieces of a pie you have a big pie with
all these pieces and you're playing this
little piece and this little piece and
this little piece and they're out of
sequence so you really have to figure
out where they fit
and I the other thing that I do that I'm
it's my idea I don't know if it's an
original idea I said you know title if
you get two or three scenes title each
scene like each scene if it's as if it's
a movie as if it's a book give it a
title you can't play the title but it
puts it in context we have to understand
the story
when you're working on stage you're
doing the whole story every night from
beginning to middle to end when you're
working on film you're doing a little
tiny piece of the story here and a
little tiny piece of the story there so
you do have to understand the story what
is the story that you're telling what is
the story about and it's frankly much
harder I mean it's way harder
it's not an instinctive thing it's
something you do have to learn and you
have to practice and get better at and
you're doing different angles of it
let's do the take from this side and
yeah it's it's quite I have always found
it to be harder acting on stage for me
anyway is easy
scary
but it's easy because once the lights
come up I'm in control of the evening
I'm in control of what I have to do
I know where this has to go and I have a
working technique you develop a
technique on stage
that you also you develop a different
kind of technique for film but the
purpose of having a reliable technique
is it establishes a level below which
your work doesn't go
so it's a baseline level of of that and
so when I started in film
and I have referenced a couple times on
how awful I thought I was at the
beginning it's because I was trying to
take the stage technique and and somehow
make that work
doesn't work it just doesn't work I had
to sort of figure out how to be more
present and how to be how to work in
close-up and and how to not be
presenting but how to be in it and be
alive in it and pretend that what's
happening is happening to me as my
former student said so that is what that
is and it's for some people it's easy
for people who don't have that formal
training it's kind of easier
but if you have that training and
background it's a shift it's a shift
so when you saw yourself whether it was
on tape or whatever besides you said not
maybe being president what else I mean
did you feel like you were acting quote
unquote okay I did uh the first
show I ever did
was a show it was a big hit in the 80s a
show called Heart to Heart oh yes yes
Heart to Heart yes Heart to Heart loved
it and um I didn't know what I was doing
I got this I came to La within six weeks
I got an agent within two more weeks I
got my first job I didn't know what I
was doing I was lucky very lucky
and I show up on the set and there's a
lot of waiting around and a lot of you
know like I'm I'm used to like let's go
let's go let's go
you know hours and hours of waiting
around for your scene and I didn't know
at that time how to sort of
um manage my time down which is a big
thing for actors because you got to stay
in the zone but you got to manage that
time
so that you're not so that you're ready
at a moment's notice so there was an
older actor whose name I don't remember
on the same episode a guy I'd seen in
like a hundred
westerns and an older guy
and I said hey this is my first job and
you know I'm not getting anything from
the director
he said listen kid if he's not telling
you anything you're doing great don't
worry about it so then I watched it six
or eight weeks later when I was on with
my wife and then everyone back home my
family back in Minnesota
and I was just mortified I thought I
looked I'm like one of those bad TV
actors I used to kind of look down my
nose at
and that was like a big aha moment and I
was really
I was really motivated by Vanity
I don't want to be that bad again I got
to be better than that I was it was like
vanity
and we all have that and so I went no
that's and so I don't know how it
happened
but I well I do kind of know how I found
that the first time I was working on a
show with the great actor late great
Jack Warden
who uh you kids at home look him up it
was an amazing actor w-a-r-d-e-n correct
right right and Jack was just
I I I I was recurring on the show and I
just want to hang around him because I
thought he was such a great sure we
never talked about acting he would only
talked about baseball and sports and he
was a great guy and he was mentoring me
without knowing he was mentoring me and
we were talking about we were sitting I
was sitting in my chair he was sitting
in his chair the set's over here they
just shot his close-up we're talking
about uh whatever baseball the weather
something and the director said oh Jack
you know what we I'm sorry you are going
to be in this shot in the back I'm going
to need you for this shot and they just
done Us close enough no problem he gets
up goes over to his place on the set
and I'm watching him and I'm thinking
that's the same guy I was just talking
to there's none of this there's none of
this performance there's none of this
it's just like boom he's just there the
same person
no difference I thought oh and I I at
lunch I sat and had lunch with him
because I took any chance I could to
hang around him
and I said I noticed this I said tell me
if I'm crazy but I noticed that and it
really blew my mind how
I guess relaxed is too uh is not as
strong enough for it but how focused
and how centered he was
he said yeah
it took me about 20 years to figure that
out I went okay I get it but I that was
like a big aha moment for me because I
was getting a master class from from a
great actor right he didn't know he was
giving me a master class but he was and
so that was I think that was as I think
back on it that was kind of the
beginning of my knowing oh it could just
I'm enough
I'm actually enough I don't have to I
don't have to push I don't I'm enough
but the I that you present the the you
that you present has to be interesting
they may go back to the idea of an
examined life and being a full human
being and not just being consumed by
ambition and craziness and show business
and all that stuff
so anyway there's that story
what are your best tips for boosting
confidence
confidence is this thing that you have
to maintain
in in a business that is designed to
undermine your confidence at alter at
every turn
um I think
I just was actually talking to somebody
yesterday was having
um a crisis is too strong a word but
she's at a Crossroads about something
and
I said you know
here's your pro here's the problem we're
talking about
I said I think you need to do something
about that problem
dilemma every day do something every day
even if it's 20 minutes even if you feel
like you're not
making progress you're repeating
yourself you're digging yourself a hole
do something to get at that issue every
day because confidence is so fragile
there are people who are confident for
no apparent reason you know there are
they just have it and they can't be
dissuaded and God that's a gift that's a
fantastic gift most of us who are mere
mortals are not like that
and so uh you know back in the day when
we used to go in for in-person auditions
which I don't know if that's ever coming
back
but you you know you'd arrive at the
audition
you pull up to the gate of the studio
and you'd say I'm going to meet
so-and-so in this building and here's my
appointment they say oh you're not on
the list
okay so they got to call the office so
that's confidence number one going down
the tubes I'm not on the list then you
get on the list oh yeah yeah they've got
you so you got to park in that structure
it's like four blocks away so you got to
go park in that structure
and you're wearing a suit because it's a
it's a role that requires that and it's
like 100 degrees out you got to walk the
four blocks in the blazing sun and then
you get there and by the time you get
there you're a mess it's so it is
designed it's like a Minefield to
undermine your confidence and so
um
I'll tell you the best story that ever
happened to me and it has to do with
this issue
I was
um
I was getting I was getting out of the
shower one morning I get a call from my
agent
and they said can you be in Century City
at 10 o'clock and it was uh or whenever
it was it was I literally just stepped
out of the shower and it wasn't I live
in the valley I live in Studio City it's
rush hour in the morning
I said he said it's a movie somebody
must have fallen out you're next on the
list I don't even know what it is just
go there'll be sides for you there to
look at
so I'm like ready I'm getting in the car
and I'm trying to get through traffic
and park and and and talk about coffee I
don't know what's going on right
so I get there I see my sides I look at
them I read through it once
and the casting judges Michael are you
ready
I want sure
I just said yes I think that's a big
part of confidence I just said yes I'm
ready I wasn't ready it wasn't even
remotely ready
but I said yes so I went into this room
and again another big room I didn't know
anything about this project first person
I see is Robert Duvall oh wow yeah so I
was like okay this is what what is this
I don't even know what this is I have
this long scene
and in those days they didn't expect you
to be off book you could still have the
script with you now everyone has to be
you know off book letter perfect and all
that stuff but I had the script and I
literally had just gotten it so I get
through to the I get to the end
it's very quiet in the room and the
director his name was Billy Graham by
the way oh William Graham a fantastic
guy
he looked at me said
that was perfect
I said really
I said that's not a word we hear too
often in rooms like this he said no that
was perfect
great I said well okay thanks guys and I
left and thinking what the heck just
happened
I didn't have time to have my confidence
shaken I just had to get it done I said
yes and I did it and the instincts we
talked about earlier just kicked in I
had a take on it oh but the other thing
was it was an Israeli character so I had
to have an accent
happened to be that my kids at the time
when they were young had an Israeli
Nanny and so I was very familiar with
you and I'm good with accents I was very
familiar with it
so I did it and they called back I don't
know a week or so later they want to
have you back if they call back
and I'm thinking oh man
if I go back I'm going to probably blow
it
so no I'm not going to go back I I was a
crazy decision I said to my agent make
up something lie say I'm working I'm
available for the job but not for the
Callback
I don't know what possessed me
and uh I got it it was a job it was a it
was a Showtime movie with Robert Duvall
we shot in South America an incredible
project movie wasn't that great but it
was a great experience and working with
him was a great experience but it was
that level of
not
knowing enough to be scared to be
frightened to let it get in your head we
all get in our heads actors get it but
people do human beings do it's it's it's
so actors will get in their heads about
something and we feel we have to be
perfect we have to be I'm working with
somebody now who's who's kind of new at
this but she's really extraordinary and
I've had to sort of cure her of being a
perfectionist I said not I'm not
interested if you missed that one where
it doesn't matter if the take is great
if you like it if we like it that's what
we're going to go with and so once you
free yourself of
perfectionism
uh I think that let's opens the door for
a little bit more confidence when I work
with I've worked with a lot of people
who are dancers and athletes in
particular who are fantastically good
for acting because they are disciplined
they know they have to have training
they know they have to know what they're
doing they can't just wing it
and just oh I'm feeling it this way they
have to they actually know that they
need coaching and all that stuff and so
but they are perfectionists
dancers and athletes are perfectionists
when they transition into acting and so
it's a ques it's just getting them
confident enough to know that they can
be imperfect
and it's cool
you know sometimes when an actor drops
the line
like right now
you go oh what just happened that's
interesting you know sometimes when you
think oh What's My Line what's my name
what's my next line but you've had a
pause
it lets us in we go oh what's going on
that's cool but so it's
I do think confidence is directly
related to a sense of perfectionism and
if you have to be perfect your
confidence is going to be undermined at
all times if you accept the fact that
imperfection as long as it shows
Fidelity to the story to the script into
your character is fine it's much easier
and it's kind of what we're after anyway
I think
we talked about Tom Cruise earlier and
sort of this this composite of someone
that has unshakable confidence and is
going to get the job done but then you
think about a character like a Paul
Giamatti or Ileana Douglas who they they
show in facial expressions micros you
know like a little bit of doubt and then
we like them even more of course yeah
because they're like oh I see me in that
character exactly yeah I mean Paul
Giamatti is a great example because
he's just got that face he's got that
face that is only and the voice and he's
very good he's very very good but as I
said earlier I do think that faces and
worlds
I was telling the young woman yesterday
who I'm working with
who's got some confidence issues I said
you know if you think about it that way
like what world do you fit in you don't
fit in every world
I don't fit in every world what world do
you fit in
and I didn't get you didn't get that
role because
there's a lot of reasons you don't get
it wrong you maybe you didn't do a good
audition maybe your agent isn't
significant enough to really fight for
you maybe uh
you're too old for that character
because he or she has to be matched to
another person who's a little too young
a little young there's all kinds of
reasons and most of them are Optical
most of them are like how you look
and and so again we get back to that
blink of an eye thing so particularly
with self tapes now
I say you know you've got to you have to
somehow
be there present and right at the first
frame absolutely the first 10 seconds
are the most important I had a a woman
who is a um
I won't name her she's but she's a very
significant casting person head of
casting at a network who came to my
class she was great she was
and somebody asked and so like if
there's a lead role in a in a television
series I don't know how many people are
submitted it's thousands probably and
then they get down they window it down
and then maybe she sees the last 50 that
have gotten through the Callback process
maybe it's even a smaller number than
that I don't know and somebody asked how
do you
uh like what's the process after that
and she literally took out her phone she
went
and everybody gasped because at that
point
she knows everybody's good
who's the right fit who looks right
it's kind of that I just cast this pilot
that I produced and it was like we had
people because we had a very good
casting director so we didn't see people
who weren't good we all everybody we saw
it for the major parts was very good so
it wasn't about that it was about like
oh she's great
doesn't fit it doesn't work for this
reason or that reason so it's a lot of
that it's a lot of that and and and
that sort of uncertainty and that
capriciousness
that's very capricious
as a profession and it's kind of
borderline abusive as some profession to
be perfectly honest particularly now
when an actor gets a a 12-page three
scene self tape with 24 hours to turn
around and he or she has a work shift
that night and they have to memorize it
and they have to film it and they have
to upload it and it has to be great come
on that's crazy
it's crazy but it is what that's the new
normal that is actually the normal now
they're trying to uh they've changed
that a little bit in the UK and I think
it's smart
they've given people they they send all
these these tapes out that are
it's impossible to do what they're
asking for some people
you know 12 13 pages when a show itself
is 60 pages
you're asking people to film a quarter
of the show they overnight and it has to
be great
in in the UK they're doing a thing they
uh four page maximum
with a four day minimum
and then if it's a six then it's a six
page they have a whole formula so it's
not otherwise it just gets to be crazy
and it's a good point you set a work
shift most actors have flexible jobs
that they're doing at night and things
yeah and so yeah you can't be totally
it's become that aspect of it has become
harder because it's not personal anymore
you're not walking into the room and
developing a maybe a relationship with
that office that you've been in six
seven times they like you they keep
bringing you back
there's an energy in the room there's a
person-to-person energy
that simply can't be replicated on Zoom
but that's what it is right now that's
that's the world we're living in and it
is what it is
I'm glad to be on the 17th hole
with that
when you're given a script do you read
the entire screenplay or only the parts
that you're playing
um interesting question
depends on the time
I mean if you have a very rapid
turnaround for the audition that you you
may not be able to read the whole
screenplay
um you
uh uh there's a there's a an old actor
expression where they go I won't say the
the swear word because bsbs BS my line
bsbs BS my line
um De Niro I don't know oh okay I don't
know who said that but uh
I like to read the script if I have time
sometimes they don't send you the script
by the way
sometimes the script's embargoed and you
don't have a chance to read it if it's a
show that's on the air you can watch an
episode or two and get a feel for it for
the world and the tone and the genre of
the show but ideally if you could read
the script yeah I coached somebody
yesterday who
it's the most weird audition we she
comes to me to help explain this stuff
and I said I'm I'm I'm lost with you
and they didn't send her the script I
said so we just have to do a little
educated guessing because I don't really
know what this scene here means exactly
in the larger tapestry of of the story
so but yeah in an Ideal World if you
have the time and they give you the
script if it's a movie they usually give
you the script if it's an episodic
television show
you generally get just your sides your
scenes and you get uh you're having the
opportunity to
watch an episode or two if you have time
to do that that helps a lot that that
definitely helps a lot because then you
kind of know what is what the world is
that you're entering I did a thing oh my
this is such an embarrassing story but
I'll tell it because I didn't I was a
snob at one point
um and I've booked a guest star on
Melrose Place the original Melrose Place
I'd never watched the show
I shot the show I never watched my
episode because I just it's I thought oh
I'm above Melrose Place I'm not that you
know stupid of me anyway
did you ever watch that show
I was an extra on it okay so you
remember the set with the pool and all
that stuff so I show up the first day of
work
uh second ID is taking me to wherever
the dressing room or wardrobe areas and
I see this set and I go wow that's
amazing what is this
and she said to me this is Melrose Place
aha
I'm an idiot and it was so embarrassing
because I didn't know the show I I
booked it and I shot it
but that was a really stupid move
on my part I mean it was arrogant it was
it was it was a bad it was a bad moment
but you have to understand you know so
let's get back the original question of
do you read the script
you have however whether it's the script
or watching something online now which
when Melrose Place was on we didn't have
that I don't think it was on but you
your job is to figure out what world
you're entering
so if you can read the script fantastic
if you don't get it you've got to figure
it out other ways and that's
it comes down to that it comes down to
to the world that you're entering more
and more now shows our
um a particular World
Yellowstone is a world I mean it's an
incredible world and all these shows and
so you really do have to understand
uh what the transaction is what what
your part in that transaction is but
yeah if you can read the script great
but you know reading reading a full
script for a movie that takes an hour
hour and a half sometimes you don't have
that time
skim it or you get you know you'll get
when the audition comes in you'll get a
storyline generally speaking you've got
a storyline of what this is about you'll
get a character description sometimes
they're useful sometimes they're not
because sometimes the person who writes
them is is the third assistant who may
or may not know really in a granular way
what they're what they're describing so
and sometimes it's just educated
guessing
and it's easier in a way than it used to
be because you can look at things and
say oh or you can research that director
or that writer
you get an idea of of what it is you're
entering into
did you go back and watch that episode
of Melrose yeah it should be somewhere
online I'm sure it is I've never watched
no you haven't okay no it's all right
I'm I'm good okay I'm good I don't need
to see it okay I'm sure it's fine what
is your process for breaking down a
screenplay
um
well if I have the time I obviously will
read the whole screenplay and I want to
know
I want to know what
the larger Arc of the story is first of
all I just want to know what this is
what is this story we're all telling
breaking it down
um for an actor is very different than
breaking it down for like a director or
a DP or somebody like that
I think that
my process
is pretty
external in a way I will sort of
I had a Epiphany when I was in college
because they were teaching
kind of method-based acting and I I just
didn't get it I went oh I don't get this
this doesn't work for me
and I went into I was doing some play
and I went into the costume shop and I
was looking for a jacket or a coat and I
found this coat and I put it on I went
and I watched myself in the mirror I
went oh
oh that's the guy
so I found out that I work externally
and once the externals are in place
I can fill it in emotionally but I need
to know
kind of the north-south east and west of
the scene like okay there's the window
there's the door
I I need to know physically and whether
it's evident in the script or whether
it's just
my imagination
uh I kind of need to know that
that's me that isn't necessarily the way
to do it that's the way I do it I think
everybody has a different technique I
think all roads lead to Rome you just
got to get to Rome and everybody's
different and some people are very
internal and very emotionally I'm not I
I fill that out later once I get the
structure of it and that's kind of a
similar way that I worked when I worked
in the theater in a way as well I gotta
I have to find the structure of it
once I feel confident that once I know
the words I have to know the words
can't be thinking about the words
uh then I feel I can fill it in I can
fill it in but you know a lot of roles
that one does aren't even emotionally
that
you know they're functionary you're a
lawyer and you're and you're doing a
courtroom scene and there isn't a
tremendous amount of emotional stuff
there it's all functionary stuff to
drive the plot forward and you also have
to understand that
like
a co-star role is generally that it's
somebody who they interview for one
scene who tells you something about the
murder suspect and then you never see
them again right so you have to
understand the function of the role
those smaller roles are frankly harder
because you have very few opportunities
to really make
um
Impressions wrong word but to sort of
establish who your character is
and it's usually just you know if it's
it's all about casting if I'm well cast
it makes perfect sense and it's real
easy for me to break it down and figure
out where I have to be I did a movie in
the audition was entirely improved they
said these are the characters you're
dealing with this is your wife this is
your nephew and it was a kind of a
really good really good film it came
came out just great just won a big a
word up at cinequest
but there was very little on the page
very little on the page it was like uh
uh it was like it's about a family it's
about a death in the family it's about
um
problems relating to money and finances
and all that stuff and there's it's a
Jewish Family and there's like aunts and
uncles and they're like the Jewish Greek
chorus so they're kind of everywhere
they're in every scene but there wasn't
really a lot on the page so how do you
break that down
you kind of don't break that down you're
cast to be like oh he or she is the
right person for that oh you're playing
my wife perfect that looks great we you
know it makes sense uh chemistry wise
but I couldn't there was no way I could
break that down because
you know there were two or three scenes
but we were in many many more scenes
than that and we uh
add a dialogue that wasn't there as well
so uh that's a whole different thing I
mean the Improv thing I'm not trained in
improv but I like doing it as an
exercise it's it's fun and it's freeing
and it was fun to do an audition that
way because I didn't have to memorize it
but how could I break down that script I
really couldn't
has had to show up as that guy you know
and TR and also trusts that trust is the
name of the movie by the way and trust
that
um
what you have is right and what and what
you'll and you will you feed off of the
other people in a bit in that case in
particular because it really was this
this
six-person Ensemble of relatives who
were in every scene and making
everybody's life a little crazy so
um the only danger with that is like uh
uh patting it too much trying to make
more of it than it is
you got to be careful about that we we
had uh
one actor who may name us who was
problematic that way but it's
understanding the world it's
understanding and how you break it down
is it's different for every project I
guess is the way I would I would
understand that if it's two or three
strong scenes where you have a definite
thing to do your your the prosecuting
attorney you're the social worker you're
the doctor
those are kind of functionary scenes
that do carry an emotional uh weight if
it's a good script
so I'm very word oriented I mean that's
the other thing I'm extremely word
oriented I believe in literally being
forensic with the words like oh and I
will use this as a teaching technique
what's the most important word in that
sentence and why
and there's usually a reason and and
it's like figuring out
where where that where that lives I mean
it's really important to be I mean that
that was something that was really
um imbued in me from working in the
theater for many many years is the text
is everything and so and in the theater
you can't change a thing you cannot
change a word
so you have to work with what you have
if the text
isn't great you find a way to make it
great that's your job is to make it
better than it is
that's the actor's job is to make bad
writing be better than it appears to be
I mean sometimes I I coached an audition
the other day and
when we were done with this young woman
did a great job I said it's better than
they deserve you did a great job because
sometimes that's what it is
so if we were to take the line I need to
talk to you Michael
let's say I'm your boss yes and I've
discovered that you're playing online
poker we've had the I.T company this is
a great scene and so it's a sensitive
issue and we don't want the other
co-workers to know about it but we want
to keep you because we like you but we
think maybe he has a gambling problem so
I um
what what would be the forensics of that
sentence it's a very simple sentence of
I need to talk to you if I'm playing
that part either either giving or
receiving yeah right so
um
it's what I call a change moment that's
a change moment in a scene
blah blah blah blah blah oh by the way I
need to talk to you okay okay can we
have sure so it's it's identifying
change moments
every time there's a change
and there are even bad writing has
changed moments in it okay so like if
you're watching television if you've got
television on in the background and it's
some local news broadcast and some
person had something horrible happen to
one of their children or you're hearing
the the newscaster he's got the
microphone he's interviewing somebody
and there's been something terrible
happened then all of a sudden it goes
quiet
and you go
and that person's crying let's say or
whatever that silence this is the one
thing particularly theater actors have I
almost have an issue with I can't
generalize but we feel like we have to
get to the next thing we have to get to
the next thing and I'll just say find a
place in there to just be quiet
so that you let us in as soon as you're
quiet and it has to be earned
has to be earned in the scene but if you
like if you said to me
uh what is the line we have to talk
about his line you just gave me I need
to talk to you Michael
okay
uh what is that about
do you want to come in my office
uh yeah
yeah I'll be right back so you fill it
with pauses
you fill it with thinking
I used to do an exercise called thinking
on film where basically I would say
30 seconds
I don't want you to say one word I want
you to have an idea I want you to have
something that just happened to you
it's either good or it's bad you got a
phone call that somebody just broke up
with you whatever it is I don't need to
know what it is you have a narrative in
your head you are allowed one physical
gesture and no words for 30 seconds go
and it's fascinating because people go
people know they may not know exactly
what's happening but they kind of know
and I said don't overdo it don't pretend
to be sad just it's just here it's just
in your face and in your eyes and in
your thinking so I call it thinking on
film and you can think on film and
that's the beauty you can once you get
to that point as a
practitioner film and TV acting where
you can just think something and it
it's there
that's magic I mean because we always
we're very I I'm word oriented because
that's how I was trained but sometimes
you have to leave that behind and just
be
moment oriented be quiet for a second
and let people in
so when you said about these functional
roles that you're not playing
necessarily Pacino in a courtroom scene
you might just be a corporate attorney
who's confirming dates or something and
it's not where you're going to be over
the top stealing the show right
and so people think maybe that that's
what their function is or well you have
the row has a function within the pardon
me within the story
and that's generally on a roll like that
pardon me it's it's generally pretty
clear what it is
generally not a lot of subtext
unless uh there's something else going
on but if it's just a functionary thing
like legal stuff I've done a lot of
legal stuff
and yes I'm not a lawyer but I play one
on TV
um
it's kind of easy because
it's procedural and the the magic of it
is that you let your you just do it as
you you just do it so whatever your
neutral is not neutral my neutral is not
neutral no one's neutral is neutral you
come in with some core thing about who
you are that kind of plays through
everything so even if you're doing a
functionary role a role that's just
talking about uh you know some legal
thing
whatever whoever it is you are
and again as I said before this gets
more complex and more interesting as you
get older and you kind of are more at
home with who you are
uh that just is there and so that's kind
of what you were hired for in a way is
to be as I said earlier a dynamic
truthful version of who you already are
so the lines are just look the uh that
stuff it's like um
it's like a baked potato you can put
anything on a baked potato you can put
salsa you can put cream uh cream cheese
you can put sour cream you can put
chives but it's still a baked potato the
baked potato needs flavor added to it
that's kind of what we bring in a
functionary row we add flavor to the
baked potato
I can't believe I just said that
let's say you get a call right now from
your agent and you have a big audition
tomorrow what's the call like what
happens
well first of all I don't get a call I
get an email ah okay so it's not it's
not ring ring no there's none of that
anymore it's all impersonal I'm afraid
um
interesting because
now you have to self tape everything
so it's not like oh I have this audition
I'm going to go to Warner Brothers at
four o'clock to this building to this
room that doesn't happen anymore I don't
know if that'll ever happen again so you
have to not only think okay I have to
look at this
I also in my case and I don't know if
everyone's like this I go do I want to
do this is this something everybody want
to do because I don't care anymore and
I'm in a different place in my life if I
don't want to do it or if it doesn't
feel right I'll go I'm going to pass on
that and they seem to be okay with that
but
the first thing I do is that I freak out
a little bit because I know there's a
timeline
and I know that I'll have to drop
everything and I have to get this done I
don't tape at home
because I'm not good at it and I hire
that out I have a guy I go to I pay him
whatever it is 40 50 bucks he does it
it's great and I don't have to worry
about that because that would drive me
crazy I'm not really good at that
so then I just really have to think
about uh what is this how do I do this
how do I get off book for this the
timelines as I said earlier are very
short
so I really have to decide whether I
want to do it when I was producing
um the pilot I produced this summer
I'm on set we're out in San Dimas it's
like 105 degrees
so hot and I get an email with a 14 page
audition that was due the next day
I just said two things I said first of
all thank you
second of all can't be done
because I'm producing this thing and I'm
on set and lastly I'm not sure 14 pages
can be done in 24 hours anyway but it
won't be a problem because I can't do
this one
so it's it's different everybody's
um the audition is the job
that is the job
and that's the way I try to teach actors
to look at it you have a job it's this
audition you have to get it filmed you
have to turn it in that's the job now
you made that job may continue
you may get a call and say oh we want
then you may get a chance to earn some
money doing that job
but the audition is the job and and it's
um
there's not a lot of room for error I'm
afraid I mean it's just it's so I think
because now they're I think I I don't
know if casting directors will get angry
at me but
it's the only people who's not tired of
Zoom are the casting people so they they
if if they were going to have see 30
people in their office on a Wednesday
well they don't need that extra room
they might not need that extra assistant
because they're going to see more than
30 people because they just send out
these tapes
and I don't know if they watch all of
them
I don't know
some of them say they do and I believe
that but some probably don't
do you think in some ways though the
self-taping is easier in that you don't
have to get in your car or take the bus
or Uber or Lyft it's easier in that
respect it's also easier it's not easier
for me because I'm old and I'm set in my
ways and I don't like it but that's
immaterial it's easier for the the
digital natives the young people who
never knew a life without a phone or a
camera
um and they're really skilled at it many
of them very skilled
it's kind of easier for them because
they
can do the audition until they get it
the way they want it
in the old days you'd walk into the room
and you might not
your first take might not be good and
that may be all you get thank you thank
you for coming in
and you walk out and you do the you do
your best job in the car on the way home
so yes that aspect of it is in some ways
an improvement
but what's missing is the human element
you don't meet people you don't it's all
on that little box
then you're also
not dealing with a sea of agendas and
energies around you true yeah I mean I
think it's generational people my age uh
I don't particularly like it I'll I do
it and I do a good job with it and I
understand that how it has to be done
and
um but you also like you send it off
into the ether
and you generally hear nothing
nothing
and so you don't even get an attaboy or
a good
you know not that we all need a pat on
the back but
um sometimes you know like when you go
in and you meet someone in person and
you do a really good job with your
audition you may not get that role but
you may get something from that office
because they liked you
if they didn't even see the I mean they
may watch all the tapes but they'll
maybe only watch 30 seconds and go no
that no wrong wrong person wrong
whatever
so I don't know I mean I'd actually like
to know I'd like to be a fly on the wall
of some of those offices and see what
they do and so I know because we hired a
very good casting director for the pilot
we did and they did an incredible job
but they're also one of the better
they're been around a long time and
they're one of the better uh casting
offices
so I think it's like anything there's
there's the cream and then there's
everything else
what do you think of people posting
their audition tape online as part of
their social media I don't like it do
you think it breaks sort of a code
that's interesting question
um
well first of all sometimes there are
shows that are non-disclosures so
they're they haven't even aired yet
or sometimes they will send you what we
call dummy sides
you know what that is
I don't but so dummy sides would be like
you're auditioning for this character
and they'll say these this isn't really
the script but it's it's sides that are
like that character and you you have no
choice but to just play what you're
given you know but I know I'm posting
people post way too much online about
everything but I I I don't know that's a
really good question
everyone you know a lot of people just
want to be seen
and want to present their best life in
that way and
I don't know I don't think it's a good I
don't probably think it's a good idea
you know particularly if uh I I know
people who do that a lot actually now
that I think of it I would never do that
yeah I was just wondering how casting
directors think about it it's not
embargoed or whatever yeah well if it's
embargo obviously you should never do
that but
um
uh there's a guy that I know who's a
very good actor he's working quite a bit
he also as a as a side gig does taping
for people
and I've actually taped with him and
he's great and he did this thing I
thought was really cool because he
booked some job on the show I don't know
a guest star role of some sort and he
took his audition tape and intercut it
with the actual footage from the show to
see show you this is what I did in this
scene here's the scene as it was filmed
and I thought that was actually very
instructive and cool but that was also
done the show was had already been aired
he had access to that footage
theoretically I guess
and that was actually very teachable and
instructive to see what he did that got
that role and how it looked when it was
filmed that's kind of interesting but
yeah posting just in general
people are crazy with that stuff
when you do get this person to film your
self tape
um are you there reading lines off of
them or they're just an eye line to you
uh the place that I use
he's he's an actor himself and he's very
good and so he is the eye line I mean
now
now we're getting technical but that's
good uh sometimes in an audition you
might have three people you're talking
to and the eye lines get a little crazy
like so I often say just like pick two
have two uh have two eye lines other or
unless somebody's in the back and you
can talk to someone back there that's
different but yeah no that guy would
read with me and uh
he's actually quite good and he will
Coach a little bit I mean which I
appreciate
he doesn't overstep but I think that's
smart most people don't do that they
just
they just you know
set up the camera and go
but uh yeah no he'll read with me he's a
very he's very good at it so I think
it's
Tech you know the technical stuff
is really important the eye lines and
all that stuff
it's just key and props
they always tell you don't bring props I
said bring a prop if it helps you
I I worked with somebody yesterday
she's playing a bartender and so she had
glasses and she had a rag she threw over
her shoulder said that all helps there's
nothing wrong with that
they used to say no he can't do that
all these rules are very fluid now
right
what does it mean for an actor to make
bold choices with their character
I mean that that is a cliche let's say
make a bold Choice make a strong choice
but with every cliche there generally is
a grain of Truth or wouldn't have become
a cliche
um
I think that it's like
um if you're at the top of a mountain
and you pour some water down the
mountain it's going to go it's going to
find its way down that's the obvious way
that is the way down the water is going
to find a little regulates and it's
going to flow a certain way and most
scenes particularly if you don't have a
lot of time
you're just going to play it down the
middle because you don't have time to
really explore it and get deeper with it
I I think trying to make the less
obvious choice the choice that may not
be actually on the page
you have to understand who the end user
is the end user is the casting director
and they're looking at lots of tapes and
they're looking at lots of versions of
the same scene over and over and over
again and most people
because of either lack of imagination or
lack of time are going to kind of play
it the same way so if you can find a way
that's Justified that's earned where you
can play something a little bit off to
the side of the page not down the middle
of the page
that's what I would call a bold choice
and a smart choice
you don't want to do that just to be
different
it has to be earned and it has to feel
like it has some Fidelity to the
character and the story but I think
that's
um that's how I would Define what a bold
choice is something that does not go
down the middle because most of the time
as I said lack of time lack of
imagination and they're watching all
these tapes they're all we did that when
I cast the pilot I mean a lot of the
tapes were like
they're all kind of played the same way
and the the one person who may play it a
little differently
jumps out for whatever reason maybe it's
not smart maybe it's not right but it's
different and so it's a little like um
I like sports analogies
um
like in baseball the great Warren spawn
the winning winning his left-hander in
the history of baseball said that the
pitcher's job is to upset the hitter's
timing and the hitter's job is to upset
the pitcher's timing so I think that our
job is to sort of
break open the timing of that scene a
little bit change the rhythm of it a
little bit if you can find a way to do
that because they're going to hear it a
certain way every time over and over
again if you can find a way to
creatively and smartly
break up the Rhythm I'm I've words and
Rhythm very important to me in my own
work and and when I when I teach them
when I coach so that's what I would say
would be a bold choice
let's say you've already booked a job
now you're on set
how bold you get or no that breaks that
that disturbs the other actor in the
scene and you're upstaging someone
that's really case-by-case basis it
depends on the set if you have a really
loose improvisational set you can do
that you can try that I I worked on Curb
Your Enthusiasm
where there's no script basically
there's a story there's there are scenes
and so uh everyone's you know a lot of
funny people Larry David Ed Bagley
Richard Lewis Jeff Garland
you know they're also going to try out
stuff that's funny and some of it will
hit and some of it won't hit that's an
extreme example of where you can be bold
and try something else that's great I
don't think we're going to use that
uh but it just is different on a on a
show that is
a well-oiled machine a weekly kind of
what I call Factory television those
those shows that just go week to week
they have a template
a visual template and a tone template
that is is established that's what they
do they play to that they have like if
you watch uh SWAT
every seven minutes someone's going down
a hallway with a gun in the dark I mean
that's part of the template I'm
exaggerating but not that much so you
have to understand that and you can't on
a show that has a really strong
uh template you kind of can't do that
it just depends on the circumstance but
it's fun to play and it's fun to do
stuff that's different and out there but
you just have to kind of know your
audience and know what world you're in
what's your advice to actors on finding
their character finding their character
within a certain script or within who
they present as the full person of who
they are the latter the latter okay
um
my advice on that
is to be open to it to really I mean the
cliche is you're enough you are enough
the cliche that's kind of true but it's
only true if what you're presenting is
examined and and nuanced and interesting
um
you know don't
there's there's there's kind of a show
biz life there's a backstage life and
then there's life
and my advice is to get involved in life
do something real and
um
you know certain people are just more
inherently interesting than others this
is human nature but to find that
person that is your the core person that
you present that kind of populates
everything
that just takes time and it takes
patience and it takes
uh
kind of being honest with yourself as to
you know who who you are and and what
you know I
I what did I watch last night I watched
who was it I'm blanking on it now been
watching The Morning Show which I think
is so good
and um
oh this this actor I haven't seen him
for a long time he's an older guy named
Paul Guilfoyle who's been in tons of
stuff I haven't seen him in a long time
and he's older than me which means he's
really old
but he's like I went oh that's Paul
gilfoyle wow where has he been but he
just is there I mean he's just he's he
has not only found that thing he's he is
that thing and it's a little bit like
the Jack Warden story that I told I
think
I I don't know how you
the advice is just to be open to it and
to be willing to be honest with yourself
about who you are
because that's the whole ball game as
far as Who You Are
dominates what you can do in in the film
and television world so you really need
to get acquainted with yourself you need
to be you need to like yourself when
people say they don't get me
well maybe they don't get you because
you don't get you
once you start to get yourself people
will start to get you
is has been my experience but that takes
a long time some people never get there
and some people get there pretty quickly
what's your advice for finding a
character within the script
when you say finding it you mean
um owning it owning kind of branding it
bringing your own yeah take to what the
director sees well you're in charge of
some of that and there's some of that
you're not in charge of
all you can do
is
as my former student said pretend that
what's happening is happening to you
personally all you can do is make it
personal the other stuff you're not in
charge of there's all kinds of
um
forces at play that that kind of
subvert that I think that it's it's
knowing
it's kind of also knowing what your
strike zone is everybody's got a strike
zone like by that I mean
not everybody has to have a huge range I
mean I think that is the that is the
the goal of the young actor I can play
everything I can I can do all these
parts I can play an old man even though
I'm not an old man I can play an
Irishman but I'm not Irish they'll get
an Irishman okay they don't need you to
get they'll get an Irishman so I think
understanding who you are and
understanding where you fit and being
okay with that
because otherwise trying to please them
is a Fool's Aaron there's no pleasing
them whoever they are we always talk
about them they don't get it they don't
get me well they don't get you because
you're not present and you're not
bringing yourself to the work and it
sounds complicated it's really simple
but until you make that turn until you
make that pivot as an actor
understanding not just paying lip
service to but understanding that you
are enough
if the you that is presented is fully
examined and interesting
then it becomes easier but otherwise
it's this you know trying to please them
that's what that's the the on on the
tombstone of every failed actor I tried
to please them
does that make sense it does do you
think it happens more with younger
people
uh yes and no I mean it happens younger
people some of them
just are are moving on instincts totally
they don't even understand the subtlety
of that question
some of them so and so they're
blissfully ignorant and sometimes that's
great because lightning strikes you know
they go oh
him
and you don't even know what you don't
even know what you got but you know that
I've seen that happen a lot
but
um
it happens all the time because we want
to please we want to be picked we want
to get the gold star up in the wall
and be told we're good and we want to
get that affirmation and if we didn't
want that we wouldn't be human but we
don't always get that I mean the failure
rate if you can call it that that's a
harsh term is significant I mean how
many things do people audition for and
when do they actually book something
and I see these things on we were
talking about social media earlier
booked it with the big you know on
Instagram and stuff booked it I wanna I
wanna have one and says didn't book it
still chill still happy didn't book it
because that's the reality of it
right I mean that is the reality of it
booked it it's like this whole thing of
just presenting this
kind of phony uh confidence and and and
confidence is a hard one thing
and everybody's happy when you books I
mean you know your wife or husband or
your partner everybody's happy when you
get a job because sometimes it's a great
job too
but
um it's that it's knowing who you are
it's it all comes down to that I mean
it's just simple that way for me
how do you know what your character's
flaw is hmm
great question I don't know that every
character has a flaw
particularly in film and television when
you're doing more functionary roles
let's say you know that's a really good
question
and I don't know if I have a good answer
for it but I think
there's two things that I I often tell
people to think about that's one of them
and the other one is does your character
have a secret
like what are what are you not saying
sometimes what you're not saying is far
more important than what you're saying
what you choose not to say
uh in a scene like I'm gonna
I'm not going to say that I'm going to
say something different so you you you
watch a character shift Focus so that's
what you choose not to say is very
revealing what the flaw is
sometimes it's real self it's really
evident in the script you know if you're
playing a murderer we know what the flaw
is or we know about the the Baseline of
the flaw is uh but for those more
um
Garden variety roles sometimes they
don't have a flaw in my opinion
if we took that scene where I'm the HR
manager or your Superior writer and
maybe I don't want to let you know that
it's been in your computer so I hey I
need to talk to you so then what what
could something that I how could I
express it without actually saying that
you know we've seen you know online
gambling coming from your computer if I
am holding this secret what's a good
line what's a good way to play it
um
good great question like uh
almost like
um
starting out I think uh not as a
performance evaluation but I just want
to talk to you about you know what's
going on are you happy
things good
good
you know
um
take a look at this does this look
familiar to you
show them the thing
he's mortified
what is that
you're doing that here you're doing that
at home
both places
do you need help
we have HR department
we want to help you because otherwise we
have to remediate this or
we're gonna have to let you go
so I don't know if this is answering
your question but it's it's kind of
understanding
the way in you know the way in is
look if she was a he or she was a
horrible boss and was very
confrontational that's a different scene
entirely if it's if if the motivation of
the boss is I really like this person he
or she does a great job I want to try to
remediate this but this is a big problem
that's a different scene entirely
and it also comes down to what else do
we know about that character what else
do we know about the boss what else do
we know does he or she have uh their own
secret like I don't know if you watched
uh Ted lasso
I haven't watched it great show I hear
good things there was a you know it's
about it's about a football team soccer
team we called soccer and they had a
they had a sports psychiatrist in and
part of the season
this um African not African-American
African black woman uh in England
and she was just fantastic and and uh
really substantial and then we find out
later on
she got a drinking problem that's very
well hidden so does the act the actor
does the actor have to play that from
the very beginning the actor has a
secret the character has a secret the
character has a substance abuse problem
but the character is also in a position
of authority and reverence she's a
mental health professional
she should be above reproach but she's
not she's a human being so depending of
the vagaries and the subtlety of the
script
you know but some stuff is just cut and
dry and very flat that way B minus
writing is what I call that right
interesting so then I'm sort of
confronting you on your secret but I
have let's say I have a shopping
addiction yeah but I don't want anyone
to know that so I feel uneasy about
confronting you exactly okay interesting
yeah
what's the difference between art and
business
oh
well
they have to coexist
I mean even
um Michelangelo probably had to make a
deal to paint that ceiling right
so it was interesting lesson that I
learned very early on that's a great
question I love that
because if you don't if if someone who
is an actor or or an artist of any sort
doesn't think of themselves as an artist
first
you'll never be an artist you'll be just
be a commodity you'll be some sort of
commoditized version of what you think
you should be
but
business is business and I fell under
the
wing of a brilliant brilliant theater
director named Michael Langham who ran
the Guthrie Theater in Minneapolis and
Stratford and Canada and he directed
John gilgud in the West End I mean he
was a
genius guy and I was very lucky to fall
under his um tutelage for a while
and I looked up to him immensely as this
great artist which he was an incredible
artist he's helped set a standard for me
that I've never forgotten
but one time he he and I were talking
and I don't want to overblow my
relationship to him but we were you know
he he was very kind to me and very uh he
mentored me in in interesting small ways
I got to know his whole family
but he was talking about business and he
said you know he said you owe it to
yourself to go for the money
he said you've earned that by all the
work you've put in as an artist at some
point you will be offered some money
and you owe you owe it to yourself to
take that money because you've earned
that money and that kind of blew my mind
I thought it was really an interest I
didn't think he thought that way I
thought he lived up on a pedestal
somewhere and he didn't I mean he was a
he was a brilliant director but also
knew his business and I think the
difference is understanding that each
has a place and I mean what I don't see
enough of
is people who want to be artists
because it's not really a rewardable
virtue in a way
uh you're really encouraged to be a
commodity
more than an artist and so then you have
a then you have a sell by date
when you're just a commodity you have a
sell-by date you can be an artist for
your whole life it's not easy it's
horribly difficult and challenging but I
think that's the difference but you know
you you do have to have a sense of of
what the business is and what not the
business but business itself and
understanding that I understood that
I think because of how I was raised and
my parents and everything I always had
a very good sense of that and so that
wasn't a lesson I really had to learn
but it's
the hard part was try to be an artist
that's the hard part the business part
was easy for me it always was but to try
to be an artist and to fail at being an
artist much of the time
is the hard part is the challenge you
know I I did a
I did a one-person play about six years
ago
which was the hardest thing I ever did
my wife said why are you doing this are
you driving yourself crazy it was an
hour and a half of me talking
and it was he was also like a 90 year
old Holocaust Survivor and so it was a
whole thing and it was really
challenging I said I'm doing it because
it's there and it's been put in my world
and to not do it with me and I'm not an
artist and I want to see if I can do
that that's a really big mountain to
climb for me I'd never done that I mean
it's was so challenging and it ended up
being great it ended up being I was very
happy with the results but it took it
took some time and it took a lot of
effort but it was oh yeah I can do that
yes I have that Within Me
and I think we have to do that from time
to time one of my good friends she's a
wonderful actress herself
uh a little older than me but has had a
great career and she said I can't
believe you did that
I can't first of all I can't believe you
did it number one number two I can't
believe you did it in front of your
students you let your students see it I
said
what do you I said what are you talking
about she said well what if you were bad
and they saw their teacher being bad I
said that never occurred to me that I
would be bad
it just didn't occur to me no
not going to be bad I'm going to be
great that's the whole point but
so she was coming from a fear-based
thing like oh you shouldn't you
shouldn't uh do this in front of your
students because they look up to you and
if you are mediocre or you're not good
it's I I said if that if that thought
entered my mind I would have gotten out
of bed in the morning
so to be an artist is
the highest thing you can do but you do
have to and and I ended up producing
that so I was the businessman too
yeah would you say auditions callbacks
rehearsals and performances are the art
of acting
um
they're building blocks the art of
acting is in performance I think
I mean I had a the play that I just
referenced
I had one night
it was always good by that one night
where I was like and and two people who
are involved with the production came
back said what happened
I said I don't know it was magic it was
magic and I touched it for a second and
I never quite
got that again in that performance I I
did it was great but it wasn't that and
so that's the thing that keeps you it's
like people who play golf
I used to play golf I'm a recovering
golfer but if you hit one great shot in
a round thing like whoa what an
incredible shot it brings you back I'm
gonna play again I gotta play again I
got to do it again and I think acting is
that way when you you know
you're only you're always as good as the
best thing you ever did so I tell that
to people when you're in a down place
and you're not doing well and you're not
feeling good about your work what was
the best thing you ever did
think about that you're still that good
you just haven't accessed it right now
for whatever reason lots of reasons life
gets in the way you know whatever but
you're always that good and that's the
thing you have to hold on to because
it just tears you apart it's
heartbreaking for a lot of people
well if something is too easy though
then we lose interest exactly so exactly
there are people who have the gift and
don't know they have the gift and don't
really appreciate
how you know that they have this gift
and and don't nourish the gift
those are rare people who have that
what is the business of acting
the business of acting is
um
sustaining yourself
sustaining yourself in a career
that
allows you to have a life
I think what's happened now
and I think it's it's
um a little bit
reflective of what's happened in our
culture
and our culture will have what we now
have a lot of very rich people we have a
lot of very poor people and the middle
class has been a little bit changed I
think the same thing is true in the
acting profession you've got a lot of
people making a lot of money
and you got a lot of people not making
any money and the there used to be and I
was one of them kind of a middle class
or upper upper middle class actor where
you could make a certain amount of money
every year whether you were doing guest
star roles
two three weeks on a movie have a
voiceover campaign you weren't
necessarily a star you didn't get that
show that ran for seven years but you
were in the mix and you were working and
you could make a really good living and
build up your pension which thank
goodness I have now which is wonderful
uh I think that's kind of disappeared
it's much harder the idea of sustaining
yourself
solely as an actor
is kind of gone I hear this from people
who I really love and respect young
people who are working you look at their
resume and you go wow look what all
things you've done they have to bartend
they have to do all this other stuff so
you know for me it was voiceover I was
very good at voiceover I had a really
good career at it so that was my day job
kind of
and it was great and because it allowed
I made there were times when I made
enough money doing that when I would say
I don't want to do that audition that
for that the stupid show I don't want to
be on it again I'm a snob sometimes and
because I have a little Fu money
okay so because I'm making money doing
that
so
you know that was what we now call a
side gig but it was really like a main
part of my career for a long time and it
allowed me to be selective so the
business of it is tricky it's really
tricky and I think being able to sustain
yourself
solely by doing it
is really a challenge much more so than
it used to be
what does an actor need to know right
now about the business of acting
um it depends this it depends another
great question it depends on the stage
that they're in like when you have
people who are
graduating from their BFA program at USC
or UCLA or Carnegie or NYU one of those
places
they don't really they're starting to a
little bit kind of teach about the
business of acting
but I don't think Academia really sees
that as their job
in general they're doing more of it now
than they used to they used to do none
of it
and when I went I taught at USC for a
while and I taught a class about the
actors real
because you realize like your business
card but that's all changed now too
people don't have reels in the same way
that's a different discussion but so I
think what they need to know
are you in it for a cup of coffee or are
you here for dinner
because if you're in it for a cup of
coffee or you're just testing the water
and I tried it for a while it really
wasn't for me
fine go
with God have a good time have a
different life it's fine no one's going
to judge you
but if you're in it for the long haul I
talked to somebody recently who was a
student of mine at USC actually who I
just thinks is amazing
and
I asked her are you are you in this are
you in this
absolutely she's in it I said great then
you don't you don't need you just need
some you need to hear yourself say that
and you need to know that that's going
to be a really hard Road
challenging road but it's also brilliant
and exciting and fun it's just
everybody's route to it is different
everybody's you talk to 10 different
people who've been successful at this
they all have excuse me different
circuitous routes that they followed
that there isn't a real
tried and true template for how you
become successful at it but what they
need to know about it is that it's a
business
that it isn't personal
that it is you know your your rejection
is always personal to you
when you are rejected for something it's
personal to you
but it's not personal the casting people
they want you to get that role they
really do they're they're most of the
time they're in your corner they want
you to they want you to solve their
problem their problem is we've got to
cast this role we've seen 50 people ah
there's the solution that person just
came into this equation this casting
thing they want that to happen so it's
just a it's understanding that it's a
long slog
you know and you need also need to have
somebody
you can't do it alone
you cannot do it alone I have my wife is
incredible and she's been by my side for
decades and I could not have done any of
this without her and so you need a
partner
whether it's your best friend whether
it's a wife or husband or partner you
need somebody you need a community of
people that's kind of what my studio has
become for a lot of people
and I think any good acting studio
should be that many of them aren't but
I think it's really important that you
have a group of fellow Travelers who are
trying to all row the boat in the same
direction and will support each other
when we did our pilot
um we use some studio people and maybe
that's some people we couldn't cast
because it wasn't right for whatever we
had people show up to do extra work you
talked about being background
I know
they were driving out to the middle of
nowhere 100 degree heat just to be a
stand-in because they like what we're
about and and there's a lot of good will
that gets built up and that that is not
lost on me I think you need to have that
community of people and hopefully if
you're lucky a partner or husband or
wife or whatever to help you down the
road and to understand how hard it is
because it's super hard it's it's it's
you know you can't here's the other
thing I've learned about this
you can't discourage people
I'm not in the discouragement business
it does no good
no one could have discouraged me
they could have said oh it's terrible
don't do it do anything else it's
I was not to be discouraged
and so maybe that's a good thing maybe
that's a bad thing but discouraging
people is like spreading a cold
it's nothing good comes from it you know
you can be real with people
and tell them you know what you really
think they should work on what their
chances are that's just always a stupid
question you know what are my chances I
don't know I don't know what my chances
are you know so but it's it's just being
real with them about what it is and what
it isn't and if you're after the
commoditized version of yourself and
some people are and some people are
really good at that
you know the influencers instagramers
and they create you know right now
if there's a casting decision between
two people and one has a gigantic
following and one doesn't guess who's
gonna be and it's and it's equal they
can't make a decision
you know I was going to get the part
that's currency now
that's currency and so
do I endorse that not really but you got
to do what you got to do it's more of a
Young Person's game that aspect of it
it was a great comment that someone left
on one of our acting videos and I forget
which one but it was it had me thinking
for a while and he just said and I'm
assuming it's a he
um you know the guy in my class that
studied theater he he had to go to La
and he did and he ended up waiting
tables taking extra work and living in
slum housing that's what he called it
and he's just like like I don't envy him
or whatever
but
it had me thinking just because I get it
but he could have stayed wherever stayed
was he could have gotten a job as an
accountant nothing wrong with it right
great great very important work could
have had a nice home nice cars things
like that would he have been happy
sometimes you just have to take a risk
and and see I say I want to say put
yourself on
kind of a schedule like if you if you
come out to LA and you give it 10 years
it's a long time you give it 10 years
and you're like nowhere
maybe it is time to
redirect your life a little bit or find
something that's ancillary to that that
you actually can do and make a living at
um
I I believe in that I think making your
giving yourself really specific goals
when I came to LA
I didn't know anything I really I mean I
was the theater guy and I was a snob and
all that stuff but I there was a show I
wanted to be on
it was Hill Street Blues I wanted to be
on that show because everybody who was
anybody was on it all the smart people
watched it I said that's what I want and
I made that a goal and I and I got on it
eventually after six or seven auditions
so I always say if you have a specific
goal
you will get a more specific result if
you have a general goal like I just want
to work
no one's interested
I want to work in that I like that show
be really specific and be be be forensic
about understanding okay who cast that
show do I know somebody who knows that
office you got a network it is who you
know by the way absolutely it is who you
know
who you know gets you in the door what
you know may get you the job but it's
important to to network and to be and I
I was never someone I was never really
good at that
because I didn't want to network with
people I didn't like
and I never did kind of
you know I'm happy to network with
people who I think are cool and I like
and I'm sabbatical with and we
understand each other but if they're
just awful
I just couldn't do that that's me but
you know I mean I know some people who
are that's just they are on every red
carpet
and they and they're on every Instagram
post and then you look at their resume
and they haven't really done very much
but they're everywhere that's a
different thing entirely that's just
chasing something for your own
self-aggrandizement right well that's I
was going to ask you said give yourself
a timeline but time goes by very quickly
especially in this town there's a lot of
distractions and so if we're not really
on a path of making things happen we can
trick ourselves into thinking we're
making things happen yes and that's very
easy here in this oh yes little bubble
you know but set I mean set goals like
you you arrive in town and you
your goal is you want to have a really
good Agent within a year
maybe you will maybe you won't it's
really hard to get an agent right now by
the way really hard oh why sorry because
they're all struggling they're all
you know first of all the whole casting
equation has changed it's very much now
about
[Music]
um
ethnic casting is much a much bigger
thing than it was
uh you know multi-ethnic casting and all
that and that's great and that's you
know everyone everyone has their place
at the table but it's just it's just
harder there's more people chasing it
it's not a personal business anymore
where you really meet people
and so you you know if all you're doing
is existing on zoom and meeting people
on Zoom
it's just it's it's just different it's
so it's very impersonal frankly in in my
experience I mean it's different for me
because I I've been here so long and I
know a bunch of people and I know
you know I had somebody yesterday wants
some help trying to get an agent or a
manager and I said I'll do what I and
she's quite brilliant
and I said I'll do it I can you know
most of the time it's a no
but I do know some people who are really
top at that
and I am happy to I said but I can only
use that bullet once because once I
fired that bullet I can't fire it a
second time but that person so you got
to be ready and all that so that's the
business side of it and it's
it's just I just think there's more
people they say there's more work
but the work is everywhere so like if
there's a show shooting in Atlanta or
New Orleans or New Mexico they shoot a
lot of stuff all over
the parts that a young actor used to get
like a small co-star part in a show
they're going to cast that in Atlanta
where they're not going to fly somebody
in for that so those little building
block parts that actors used to get back
in the day are fewer they're harder to
find or we feel like we have to fill a
racial quota so we have to cast that
part this way or whatever there's lots
of different reasons they all make sense
and they all make sense economically
because it's all about the bottom line
but I just think it's I think it's
exponent it's always been hard I think
it's exponentially harder now in my
opinion
how does an actor come up with a
quote-unquote game plan for their career
maybe they're fresh from Minnesota
that's where I'm from yeah
um
uh I think you have to make a game plan
so how they come up with it you know
the basics are I need to get
first of all I need to have enough
funds where I can exist for a while I
need to get a day job I need to get an
agent I need to get a manager I need to
get a commercial agent because that's
easier to get and if I get a big
commercial that pays a lot of money so
you there's a short-term game plan
there's a long-term game plan I think
the short-term game plan is what I just
described people you know there's no
shortage of people
still coming here
still with the dream you know and and it
still is the center it's still the
center of the talent business
um Los Angeles New York as well I mean
New York is is similar in that way
uh and so I think the game plan is
originally uh the the initial game plan
is survival
get a job get a place to live get a car
get a you know and and call everyone you
know who knows anybody and see if I can
get a Toe Hold find a class find a
teacher find a coach whatever
and that ends up sometimes just being
the only game plan people have because
they can't
they can't move off from that there are
those who um
it's like I'm going to do another golf
analogy
like they're people who hit balls on the
driving range and there's people who
play golf
so people who are class rats who are
always in class who've been in class for
10 years 12 years and I have some of
those and they but the ones I have work
they also work they're in class for a
while
they they're not in for a year or two
they come back for a year or two that's
different but the people who never
venture out of that bubble of class
they're hitting balls on the driving
range but they're not playing the game
of golf because the game of golf
requires oh there's a downhill lie oh
there's a water hazard there oh I'm in
the sand what do I do so it's different
so that the short-term plan is getting
all those things together
uh the survival stuff the long-term plan
is I'm a Believer and you have to make
the plan set the goal and and the goal
posts are often moving and fluid because
things change you know you either get
some people get very lucky there are
people I I know a lot of them
bless them got very lucky if something
happens and they just fall into it and
some people you know we all know
pardon me we all know really talented
actors brilliantly talented actors
who've never gotten any traction in
anything I know people like that
and it's hard it's hard for them
it's hard to see some of them give up
some of them don't and you know see
people of very modest mediocre talents
who who do very very well whether they
have a game plan or not I always think
you have to have it you have to create
it and have it and know that it's
changeable because only thing that's
constant in this endeavor is change the
amount of changes that I have seen
starting in my early early career to now
are just mind-blowing I mean
and at a certain point you go I don't
want any more change I want it to stay
the way it is but it never does of
course so you have to adapt
and you have to adapt to what's new
what's fresh what people are interested
in what people are looking for with
people
what about you
will resonate in some way that you never
thought of before
so having the plan is important but also
knowing that the plan is very fluid and
changeable is also important because
most plans don't work most plans have to
be adapt you have to be adaptable and
and you know when I when I first bought
my house
I was working a lot and then all of a
sudden nothing
and I had this guy this great guy
next we had these next door neighbors
who were about billions they were a
Vaudeville dance team oh wow phenomenal
just amazing people
and he had been an actor and he knew I
was an actor I didn't know him very well
and he knew I was an actor and he kind
of he
he came up to me I had been in the house
three four months and all of a sudden
work had just dried up and I had a house
payment to make
and we were starting family and all that
stuff and he said and he was like a
really like almost like a Damon Runyan
character he was an old-timey New York
guy great guy
and he said how's it going kid
I said eh not so good
really that's all right it'll get better
it's like a straight car a new one
always comes by and uh he said you need
anything I said uh what do you mean you
need a touch do you need a little money
he hardly knew me wow I said no but no
no thank you but no he said well if you
ever need anything you come to me kid I
said that's on the level kid it was like
I'm talking to a Damon Runyan character
but I mean his was the guy who had been
in Show Business his entire life he was
in his 80s at that point and he started
as a kid and had been on Broadway had
been on The Ed Sullivan Show and have
been and so he knew that the long
trajectory of the career
he knew stuff that I didn't know I was
freaking out because I just bought a
house and stopped working
you know but so that that plan is is
it's as valuable as the paper it's
written on which is means it's you got
to have it but you have to also have to
understand how it moves and Shakes and
you've got to be adaptable and reinvent
reinvent reinvent reinvent that's what
it is
are there any don'ts you've mentioned a
lot of wonderful dues on the game plan
uh what about don'ts
stay away from this
be cautious of this
don't fall under the influence of a guru
because there's a lot of that which I
think is really hurtful and harmful
um
how do you know they're a guru though
well
when you get into what this is a good
question because many of the people who
are gurus are also quite brilliant
and they attract followers and
you know they're a guru when let's just
say in an acting class but they're it
happens in other areas too
when it becomes about pleasing the
teacher and not about your own personal
growth you're in the presence of a guru
you're in the presence of a narcissist
this is very common
very common I have seen it I've seen
people who've been involved with uh some
acting Studios that won't be named where
I've had to I won't use the word
deprogram but like I had one guy who was
a fantastic actor
and he was with this place for two years
and he said I don't even know how to act
anymore I've just I'm destroyed I don't
have I've lost whatever it is I had well
then you know you're in trouble right
that's that's not good so you have to
understand
you have to have a judgment is like
who's throwing the BS and who isn't and
what's the truth what's the MS the truth
which is Yiddish for truth you've got to
be after the MS the truth and so
some people have bad judgment and they
don't know and they they they learn the
hard way or they get stung or they get
abused or whatever there's a lot of that
so I mean
it's really important to surround
yourself with people who understand what
you're about so don't fall under that
influence the other don'ts are like
don't sell yourself short
don't decide that you're only you're
only worth being at this level
um when I was talking to this young
woman yesterday who I'm trying to help
out with maybe finding a new manager
she's brilliant I mean she's I don't
throw that word around she's brilliant
and I said
you deserve that you deserve somebody
really good because you are outstanding
you're an uncommon talent and so and I
think she needed to hear that
I said do you know that about yourself
quiet
said know that about yourself that's
important because you are that way and
you deserve somebody great and so
you don't deserve you know there's a lot
of bottom feeders
who are agents managers whatever
and um
so know your worth
don't fall under the bad influence
and stay interested
stay interested I often ask people what
do you like what are you are you
watching something that interests you
who are your Heroes who do you like
who's great why don't you elect that
person that's interesting but you know
to sort of develop a taste level that's
high
the great Ira Glass quote you know that
quote
it's about writers but it's really about
anybody who's doing anything creative he
based I'm going to paraphrase it but
it's a brilliant quote he basically says
that when you start doing something
creative
you have a taste level that's really
high that's what got you into it because
you you understand what's good but for
the longest time your work isn't as good
as what your taste level is and the only
way to get there is to just do lots and
lots of work to just continue to do work
to fail upward a little bit let's say so
that at some point
your level of talent and skill matches
your level of taste
so I can see things like I'm watching
The Morning Show right now which I think
is brilliant
and I go wow I mean I would love to be
in that and
I could play in that playground when I
did uh big little lies it was like I
hadn't worked for a little while because
I've been doing other things I've been
teaching writing books doing all that
stuff I went oh I've been invited back
to the grown-ups table that's what it
feels like and I was nervous
but as I was nervous for no reason it
was great it went great and it was fun
and it was I I felt
um validated in that way and so I think
it's understanding
what you're worth and a lot of that is
just who you know a lot of that is
who you are you know what you know
everybody's got some
bad stuff in their background that holds
them back an abusive parent or whatever
we've all got something
but it's understanding your story what's
your story who are you that worldview
exercise who are you what's your story
and do you deserve that if you don't
think you deserve it you're in the wrong
line of work you've got to believe that
and um
sometimes you get lucky and you and you
get you get to play with
people at a very very high level and
whenever I've been lucky enough to do
that
it's been just like
it should feel logical that you're there
oh this makes sense that I'm here with
Robert Duvall or Paul mazurski or
somebody else
that just makes sense because that's
what I've been working toward that's how
I see myself
so it's a lot of self actualization and
really and and positive thinking and
um my mother used to say I'm going to
give you a Dutch uncle talk and she
would tell me she would build me up she
was a little nuts my mother but she
would build me up in ways that were
really helpful and it's it's important
to build yourself up and have people
around you not to shine you on not to
tell you how great you are when you're
not but to really
share the dream that you have with you
as much as they can it's it's only going
to be your dream but to share it with
people like-minded people whether it's a
partner or community